E aí
[Música]
hoje eu vou falar sobre a magia do
computador e sobre a magia do jogo de
búzios
e parece para dançar mas não é
e em algum lugar o computador e o jogo
de búzios encontra inclusive em 1989
e eu depende na Universidade de São
Paulo
o Itaú sim
é a minha tese de doutorado em ciência e
e eu ando a dizer algum sistema jogos de
dados africanos esse jogo
e eu analisei o jogo Vivo On
e a tese foi defendida pelo professor
matemática pedagogo brasileiro Oswaldo
só um
se apresentam demonstrou que o jogo de
búzios é o computador
a equipa seguinte eu não vou aqui
comprovar vou explicar como que eu
cheguei a esse desejo então vou falar
sobre o computador e sobre o jogo de
búzios onde estão as magias dos 21
e o computador Vamos começar com coco
com o
e o que é o computador e
o computador e uma máquina
é uma máquina de processamento de dados
e de informação
e o computador onde é dividido em duas
partes de uma maneira geral
o ataque vida
o impacto invisível ataque de vidro os
ingleses chama ela de a máquina pesada
e pela parte que você está vendo pode
colocar por transportar pode quebrar
Pode chutar
e agora a outra parte chama assim não
o alface
Oi Neide a parte de vidro a parte
hardware com até hoje componentes
eletrônicos
a imagem com que o computador começa a
funcionar
e agora a parte visível a estátua ela
qualquer Ok os programas e as
instituições
O que fazer com que o computador possa
obedecer essas instruções e na Bahia
e quando você compra hoje o seu
computador ele vem complexo mas o nos
anos 80 quando a gente comprava o
computador ele vinha só com o sistema
operacional e se chamava ou se chama
ainda conquistou para quem se tem sem
ele nada funciona é você tinha aqui
instalar outros sistemas operacionais
hoje você recebe o seu computador com o
doce odor e ao mesmo tempo com o Google
ou Nemo então este é o computador vamos
ver se o jogo de búzios também esse é
fácil
e agora outros mas o que olha o nome
dele computador do inglês Campo nada
bom então o computador passou que ficar
cura
e agora os franceses não chama o
computador de computa
e ele chama de ouvir Natal porque para
eles o computador não sou calcula mas
ordena ele traz outras coisas Você pode
cantar música Espetacular Eu perguntei
calcular
É sim porque ele ele só vai calcular
para deixar sair o som Então o que fazer
o computador calcula agora pouco
computador ele evoluiu muito ao longo do
tempo na segunda os historiadores
europeus o computador começou lá na
China como máquina de calcular Ábaco
chinês mas eu sei que o computador
começou na África as seis minami toma
banho buscar e depois então temos a
máquina de calcular de passar o francês
Blaise Pascal e a máquina computador de
Turim Isso aí são assim eram as máquinas
só que a máquina de turing ela
funcionava com engrenagens então não era
assim o computador mas era o início
e depois o computador e Wii U
eu vou usar os 45 criou-se o primeiro
computador
e se chamava Eniac um nos Estados Unidos
ele era um computador gigante enorme e
se ele tava para caramba só para fazer
uma igual 21
o e precisar desse triângulo para dizer
agora calcule o + 2 = 3
e os tubos esquentava muito então houve
também uma evolução do computador como
estão vendo aí do Grande até o pequeno
que nós temos hoje esse pequeno telefone
que você quer mas a partir dos anos 60
descobrir assistir ao invés de conduzir
a energia elétrica unicamente através de
Condutores é tipo fio de cobre ou de
Prata descobriu-se os semicondutores e
e aqui dos anos 60 acho que todo mundo
de ouvir falar e Vale do Silício mando
tudo eu começo Então a partir desse
materiais semicondutores começou a
esfriar ou se componentes eletrônicos e
fazer com que o computador vai ter um
tamanho muito pequeno
nós temos aí um dos componentes o dildo
o diodo ele combo da energia a
eletricidade de um lado para o outro no
sentido só um
e quando você inverte o sentido o que
acontece ele não conduz mais
o beija-flor ele conduz
a Índia Peu ele não conduzem magro
o Google sim sim
se inverteu com duas não sim não não não
estamos nos aproximando de um conceito
muito importante eu vou falar sobre isso
agora temos outros componentes tem que
tomar da frase engolir energia e guardar
e depois ele pode vomitar na energia
engoliu 11
o jogo
o capacitor Aí temos o camarada mais
importante ao meu ver do computador e se
chama não existe o trânsito iniciam
outro nome que é o amplificado ele tem
várias formas como vocês estão vendo aí
sem o amplificar com 5 transistores
operacional se ele faz todos os cálculos
e o computador não pode fazer sozinho
por quê Porque o computador sofás adição
ele não faz outra coisa mas ou
transistor você estar enganado ele
permite que se passa outros Campos Então
a partir daí vamos ter OK os
computadores digitais e quanto que os
primeiros era simplesmente analógico 1
e o computador vai lá eu disse uma
língua
e a linguagem dele chama-se linguagem
binária
a linguagem binária ouvir Pioneer Digite
o dedo e Total 2 oitavas ou é verdadeiro
ou é falso ou é um ou exemplo é esse
aqui é o sistema numérico binário é um
sistema do computador Então temos o
dígito binário e só tem dois valores
olha vamos aproveitar resgatar o
comportamento do trânsito aí você a
forma de onda do trânsito lembra venda
em loja barriga para cima um barriga
para baixo Z agora como usar nossa
língua usamos sinais
é mas usamos fazer palavra O computador
também usa a palavra
é o tamanho
o mínimo da palavra do computador é
composta de 8 bits então a palavra do
computador é chamada de bar Dom a
memória vai ter organizada da maneira a
seguir
o presidente para o endereço é
a combinar 000010 um gelo mas nesse caso
você terá quatro os endereços oi oi
bom então já tem o endereço vai ser o
representado ou 13 eu quero também que
você possa se lembrar não sou daqueles
cima barriga para cima barriga para
baixo Mas também de se você sair
trânsito Ok quando vou falar do jogo de
vôlei tomar lá são muito bem então 13
para Winder
15 bits para o o isso aí e comprou um
computador de 8 bits já que eu falei
então do sistema de navio do computador
a magia do computador onde está mais é
do computador está no ar do Uno a
resposta aí ó
e a magia e disse agora vamos para rodar
o jogo do ele é o jogo adivinhação mas o
jogo de búzios é um pouco nem jogo de
música de 8 com tem jogo de burro 16
Conchas quando não temos oito com chance
e o pai-de-santo vai jogar um
o orgulho é uma conta são dois deitados
saiu ou ele cai barriga para mim
oi oi cara ele tem fábrica para o rui
rocha kerner barriga para cima um
comparando com o sistema do trânsito
barriga para baixo 0 no computador se
usa 3 bits para representar o endereço é
no jogo de buzio se usa 3 bits para
representar o tema
E isso não é a mesma coisa é a mesma
coisa então seu computador usa 13 bits
para representar o endereço é que o jogo
de búzios de 8 Conchas usa preso Conchas
para a representa o tema a conclusão
lógica é os dois são computadores agora
o pai-de-santo a função dele é de
responder às perguntas essa parte de
adivinhação não não me interessa aqui o
que me interessa a parte lógica e
matemática do jogo de búzios
o ok então eles uma vez de vez em quando
eu falo francês mas entenda uma vez uma
vez que ele jogou e que o santo
respondeu Ele joga de novo as oito
Conchas
é porque o que vai acontecer ele vai
interpretar agora seis e Conchas para
poder ler a resposta a uma pergunta
e fez concha no computador para
representar um registro era Quanto
quantos bichos isso mesmo 5
é muito bem e aqui para representar uma
resposta quanto quantas Conchas seis é a
mesma lógica quer então o jogo de búzios
é um que conclusão podemos tirar
Olá eu sou negro só vai ficando por eu
sei o quanto se diz que a África não deu
nenhuma contribuição para a ciência para
a tecnologia África deu África e a
origem do ser humano a África é a origem
da ciência a África a origem da
Matemática Vamos mudar de maneira de ver
Vamos acabar com esta invisibilidade da
Verdade muito obrigado a
E aí